vuelos cancelados puertos y negocios
cerrados y ciudadanos evacuados algunas
de las medidas que se tomaron en el este
de china ante la llegada del tifón y pnv
hasta que se prevé toque tierra esta
noche hora local de los vientos que
registran una velocidad de 137
kilómetros por hora según la
administración meteorológica china
amenazan en especial a shanghai pero
también a las provincias cercanas de
zhejiang fujián jiangxi sin embargo las
autoridades tomaron sus precauciones
evacuaron a los pobladores y les dieron
refugio temporal todo está bien el
gobierno y los funcionarios han
organizado bien la comida la ropa y el
alojamiento
esto se da mientras la provincia central
de henán sufre las consecuencias de las
lluvias torrenciales que derivaron en
inundaciones dejaron al menos 58 muertos
un millón de personas fueron reubicadas
y algunas se vieron afectadas por la
falta de agua y comida durante unos días
según los expertos esto está relacionado
con el calentamiento global suave
las inundaciones en alemania y las
inundaciones en jinán ambas con lluvias
fuertes tienen obviamente una conexión
con el calentamiento global el tema es
el siguiente cuando se incrementa la
temperatura en la atmósfera también se
incrementa la temperatura del agua y por
eso hay más evaporación de agua en la
atmósfera
este año china ha sufrido inundaciones
históricas en la más reciente que afectó
en particular a zhengzhou se registraron
610 milímetros de lluvia en tres días el
equivalente a lo que llueve en casi un
año según la estación meteorológica de
esta provincia además se registraron
severos tifones el infa es la sexta
tormenta tropical y el tercer tifón en
lo que va del año